à 36 ans jérôme est un pro du volant
mais d'ici quelques jours il pourrait
devenir l'un des as de sa profession il
est en effet sélectionné pour participer
au traditionnel trophée des routes
c'est un petit challenge en plus voilà
ça fait bientôt 18 ans que je roule
c'est mon formateur qui m'a demandé j'ai
accepté de le faire
voilà on verra bien la suite j'ai fait
que du frigo donc après je connais pas
tout le corps du métier
mâchez etc samedi challenge à faire pour
mettre de son côté le maximum de chance
jérôme multiplie les entraînements comme
ici une simulation de mise à quai le
tout se déroule sous l'oeil aiguisé les
remarques de fabien c'est le formateur
de l'entreprise la cei de faire un arrêt
de précisions l'essentiel c'est de ne
jamais donner deux congo coup de volant
tout simplement fait très souvent la
manoeuvre des conseils pour des surfeurs
expérimentés comme jérôme y en a pas
beaucoup lui apporter c'est juste des
rectifications
c'est juste repenser leur conduite des
épreuves pratiques sur piste et sur
route sont au programme du concours mais
aussi toute une partie liée à la vie au
sima qui est plus surtout code de la
route il ya un an 18 ans que j'ai parmi
les dents les pistes donc ça va être un
peu compliqué pour toi de la route c'est
plus
en fait tout ce qui touche la technicité
des polos en fait c'est pas trop le code
en lui-même que c'est
par exemple et pour les nombreux
messieurs temps de tonnes et tout voilà
c'est plus compliqué quoi la solitude de
gironde derrière son volant n'est qu'une
image car il sait qu'il ne va pas seul
au concours
toutes ces entreprises et avec lui on
est tous derrière a poussé un chauffeur
qui est quand même un peu l'expérience
moi personnellement ça fait 15 ans tu de
l'entreprise donc ça commence déjà à
faire quelques années le chauffard l'a
été la déjà avant nous et on sait que
c'est un bon chauffeur qui représentera
les entreprises en attendant de
concourir et jérôme essaie de ne pas se
mettre trop la pression même si
forcément lorsqu'il roule
il fait encore plus attention